pas de doute inspecteur c'est un
homicide
il y a environ 10 000 ans au
Proche-Orient certains humains ont cessé
d'être nomades et sont devenus peu à peu
des agriculteurs cette évolution qu'on a
souvent décrite comme une révolution la
fameuse révolution néolithique a
transformé les sociétés en profondeur
architecture technique alimentation
richesse pouvoir tout a changé les idées
et les croyances aussi malheureusement
pour les préhistoriens il est très
difficile de savoir ce que les gens
avaient dans la tête comme on ne possède
pas de texte à cette époque il faut se
baser sur d'autres indices l'art et les
symboles le symbole le plus répandu au
début de la révolution néolithique et
sans conteste le bovin pain gravé ou
sous forme de crâne il est partout
on considère souvent qu'il représente un
symbole masculin et associé à des
figures féminines qu'on connaît sous
forme de statuettes notamment ils
formeraient le premier couple divin à la
base des religions postérieures c'est en
tout cas ce que beaucoup d'archéologues
ont postulé dans la lignée de
l'archéologue français Jacques Cauvin
pour lui c'est la manifestation d'une
grande révolution des symboles qui
précède et accompagnent la révolution
néolithique à regarder de plus près
toutefois le thème des bovins est déjà
largement développé avant le néolithique
disons et au rock ont été représentés
dans des dizaines de grottes du
Paléolithique tout comme le thème
féminin d'ailleurs on connaît de très
nombreuses statuettes de Vénus et
néolithique ne semble pas avoir inventé
grand-chose de ce point de vue là
alors s'agit pas de dire que covins se
trompait complètement bien sûr il savait
tout ça et il décrit plutôt une nouvelle
manière de représenter ses symboles dans
des nouveaux contextes mais il y a bien
une évolution des symboles au
Néolithique notamment avec l'apparition
de thèmes inconnus des ancêtres
chasseurs-cueilleurs parmi eux il y a un
symbole récurrent qui a obsédé les
humains pendant plus de 4000 ans dans
une bonne partie du Proche-Orient les
crânes humains et les vautours
[Musique]
la première fois qu'on a repéré ce
symbole c'était dans les années 60 dans
le sud de la Turquie au village
néolithique de châtelauduc les fouilles
ont mis au jour des centaines de maisons
en terre datant du septième millénaire
avant Jésus-Christ elles étaient
construites les unes contre les autres
et on y accédait par les toits certaines
d'entre elles étaient riches mon
décorées avec des reliefs ou des
peintures en plus de nombreux bovins et
de quelques figures féminines
l'archéologue britannique James Mella
exhume dans plusieurs maisons des
peintures murales qui montrent de un
grand vautour avec leur silhouette
menaçante elle déployée ils ont l'air
tout droit sorti d'un cauchemar d'autant
qu'ils sont réunis autour de corps
humain sans tête et semblent les
attaquer en plus de ça sur le sol en bas
des peintures et tes déposées en crâne
humain scène exceptionnelle dans le très
riche des corps de Châteloy Youk où les
bovins et les Panthères sont
majoritaires le thème des vautours et
des crânes intrigue les préhistoriens
dans les décennies suivantes d'autres
découvertes alimentent le mystère plus à
l'est dans la haute vallée de l'Euphrate
le site de Neva le chorry a livré
plusieurs sculptures de vautours posées
sur des têtes humaines ou associées à
des corps sous les maisons du site les
archéologues ont retrouvé des dépôts
d'ossements notamment des crânes qui
avaient fait l'objet d'une attention
particulière l'un d'eux est en même posé
sur un couteau en silex enfin certaines
sépultures du site avaient des crânes
manquants cette pratique est connue dans
de nombreux autres sites de la région
comme cortic TP et châtaigneux que dont
on vient de parler les fouilles récentes
du site dans les années 90 ont repéré la
marque de coupe sur des vertèbres une
planche en bois était posée sur le corps
pour s'appuyer dessus pendant
l'opération plus bas dans la vallée de
l'Euphrate le site de jeffel armar est
d'un apport considérable fouillé à la
fin des années 90 par les équipes de
Daniel storder il a livré des
représentations de corps sans tête et de
vautours dans l'un des bâtiments
communautaires ces grandes salles semi
enterrées qui ont fait la renommée du
site une dalle décorée de trois corps
sans tête était encadré par deux têtes
de vautours sculptées plus
impressionnant au sol un corps sans tête
d'une jeune femme était étendue sur le
dos les bras en croix cette mise en
scène macabre réalisée avant la
destruction volontaire du bâtiment et
complétée par le dépôt de crâne au fond
de trou de poteau
à gobeclit TP célébrissime sanctuaire du
tout premier néolithique en plus des
nombreuses représentations d'animaux
sauvages et menaçants le pilier numéro
43 montre plusieurs vautours et un homme
sans tête
une petite figurine interprétée comme un
vautour a aussi été trouvé sur place on
pourrait continuer dégrainer les
trouvailles de ce type le site de
numeric en Irak à livrer des
représentations de vautours et des
crânes isolés à mouraï bet en Syrie un
crâne était posé sur un support en
argile le site d'assela rend Turquie
livre 4 crânes isolés et à Chaillot ce
sont 71 crânes qui ont été mises au jour
dans un seul bâtiment
[Musique]
ailleurs notamment dans la vallée du
Jourdain les crânes sont même utilisés
pour confectionner de véritables
reliques a-t-elle à soi bensamun n'gazal
Jéricho et d'autres sites de la région
les humains du Néolithique ont
reconstitué des visages avec du plâtre
et de l'argile c'est ce qu'on appelle
les crânes surmodelés déposez en groupe
dans des fosses ils sont à mettre en
relation avec les sépultures sans tête
trouvées à proximité akfar aoresh en
Israël de nombreuses sépultures
centrales sont trouvées sous des couches
de sol en plâtre ce qui fait penser que
les crânes servent de dépôt de fondation
avant la construction des bâtiments à
engazal en Jordanie des sépultures
centrales mais présentant encore la
mâchoire montre que le crâne a été
prélevé après des compositions du corps
un peu plus tard cette pratique est
aussi documentée en Turquie à Cosco Yuk
sur 19 crânes retrouvées sous les sols
des maisons 13 portaient des traces de
plâtre parfois colorées sur ce site on
possède aussi des squelettes sans leur
crâne mais avec leur mâchoire un crâne
sans modeler était aussi présent dans
une tombe à châtaigne dans les bras
d'une femme inhumée le crâne était
couvert de plusieurs couches de pigments
rouges on le voit il se passe quelque
chose au néolithique au Proche-Orient
avec les vautours et surtout avec les
crânes en plus tous les sites
archéologiques qu'on a mentionnés ne
sont pas contemporains et ils montrent
que cette obsession a perduré pendant au
moins 4 millénaires en gros entre 10000
et 6000 avant Jésus-Christ bien sûr les
archéologues ont proposé de nombreuses
théories pour essayer d'expliquer ça il
y en a quatre principales
hypothèse numéro 1 un rituel
dès la découverte de la première
peinture de vautour à châteloyc James
Mellaert fait le rapprochement avec les
tours du silence ces édifices qu'on
nomme dakhma en farsi servait chez les
masséistes d'Iran c'est une religion à
exposer certains cadavres pour qu'ils
soient dévorés par les vautours alors
c'est un rituel assez rare mais qui a
frappé l'imagination des étrangers
depuis longtemps lors de la découverte
des structures mégalithiques de
gobéclité certains pensent aussi à cette
possibilité après tous les cercles de
pierre sont situés en hauteur loin d'une
source d'eau et aurait été facilement
repérable pour les oiseaux c'est à
mettre en lien avec la trouvaille en
grande quantité d'ossements de corbeau
qui représente plus de la moitié des
restes de faune à gobéclid TP et des
ossements d'autres animaux charognard
dont les vautours mais l'art imaginez
même que tous les corps retrouvés sous
les maisons de chattaloyke avait
préalablement été décharné par les
charognards mais l'analyse précise des
squelettes dément aujourd'hui
complètement cette hypothèse d'autant
que Mellaert au même mentionné
l'absence de tête sur les peintures et
le fait que la plupart des inhumés ont
encore leurs têtes donc si ce sont bien
des rides funéraires qui sont
représentés c'est un peu étrange parce
que ça veut dire que ça concerne pas
toute la population ça ne concerne pas
ceux qui sont inhumés avec leurs têtes
associées aux serpents symboles très
présents aussi à cette époque comme sur
un galet gravé de dire fail armar ou les
piliers de gobéclit TP le vautour aurait
pu jouer le rôle de passeur entre les
mondes le serpent est en lien avec
l'inframonte et le vautour avec le ciel
il aurait donc un rôle psychopompe
faisant passer les âmes vers l'au-delà
cela a fait pencher certains
archéologues pour la théorie d'une
religion de type chamanique au
Néolithique et après tout pourquoi pas
dans cette perspective les restes de
vautours sur les sites auraient pu
servir à élaborer des costumes ça en
tout cas ce que suggère l'étude réalisée
par l'archéoséologue Lionel gourichon
sur le site de jeffel Harmar après une
étude minutieuse des restosseux il
semble que le vautour n'a pas été abattu
pour sa chair à la différence des autres
oiseaux
les traces de découpe se concentrent sur
les ailes et le crâne sans doute pour
exploiter des plumes et fabriquer des
habits cérémoniales et des traces
similaires sont d'ailleurs présentes sur
le site de Feunard basseux de quoi
relire différemment les peintures de
chattaloyke les deux vautours Unis de
jambes étrangement humaine autour d'un
homme sans tête sont peut-être des
prêtres déguisés en train de réaliser un
rituel funéraire
hypothèse numéro 2 un culte des ancêtres
une deuxième hypothèse assez évidente en
ce qui concerne les crânes prélevés dans
les tombes et le culte des ancêtres la
pratique du surmodelage serait alors un
moyen de conserver les traits et le
souvenir du défunt les crânes retrouvées
enterrés correspondrait dès lors à des
objets désaffectés ayant fini leur vie
de relique après la dernière étape d'un
parcours rituel à ingaza les gerico les
deux crânes retrouvées sur le sol de
maison incendiées étaient peut-être des
reliques toujours en activité détruites
dans un incendie accidentel
l'archéologue Catherine Perlès fait le
point sur cette théorie elle rappelle
qu'aucune sépulture sans tête n'existe
en contexte paléolithique et que le
phénomène apparaît en revanche dès le
natuien au Proche-Orient c'est-à-dire
dans les premières sociétés sédentaires
elle y voit la naissance d'une filiation
territorialisée des dynasties locales en
quelque sorte honorés par un culte des
ancêtres de quoi relire une autre
peinture de Chateau sur la scène de
chasse au cerf d'une des maisons trois
personnages sans tête et parfois de
couleur différent e pourrait être des
ancêtres héroïques participant à la
chasse avec les vivants
[Musique]
hypothèse numéro 3 la chasse aux têtes
cette troisième hypothèse est proposée
par Alain Testard un anthropologue qui
nous a beaucoup inspiré et qu'on a déjà
beaucoup cité sur cette chaîne d'après
lui la symbolique des vautours et des
crânes n'est pas une expression d'un
rite funéraire ou d'un culte des
ancêtres mais plutôt de la guerre car
même si quelques sociétés ont utilisé
les vautours pour leur rythme funéraire
ça reste extrêmement rare et aucune ne
décapite préalablement les défunts le
vautour et la décapitation sont
d’habitude associées à des cadavres
abandonnés sans sépulture en général des
ennemis vaincus niconographie plus
tardive du Proche-Orient le rappel en
Mésopotamie la stèle des vautours qui
date de 2450 avant Jésus-Christ ou en
Égypte la palette de Narmer 700 ans plus
tôt montre des ennemis nus décapités et
dont certains sont dévorés par les
oiseaux il ne s'agit pas d'un rituel
mais bien d'un massacre pour tes stars
il est improbable de représenter un rite
funéraire aussi macabre sur le mur d'une
maison comme à châtelottes en Irak les
tours du silence sont des lieux impurs
et interdits d'accès
ne représente pas les peintures
funéraires représentent en revanche le
défunt dans toute sa gloire en train de
festoyer ou de chasser mais certainement
pas sans tête et en train de se faire
dévorer cette représentation doit donc
avoir à faire avec le prestige d'avoir
tué des ennemis ce qui est beaucoup plus
courant on peut à nouveau en trouver un
écho à châtaigne les fresques seraient
donc des souvenirs d'exploit guerriers
et les crânes trouvaient à proximité
pourrait être ceux d'ennemis rapporté en
trophée comme ça existe chez de nombreux
peuples qui ont pratiqué la chasse aux
têtes cela pourrait être en adéquation
avec une autre peinture du site
malheureusement très mal préservé on y
voit une tête avec les yeux fermés qui
semblent avoir été portées par un
personnage dont le seul torse est
préservé c'est peut-être la plus vieille
représentation au monde d'une tête
coupée en suivant cette hypothèse le
bâtiment de Chaillou qui a livré 71
crânes serait donc un lieu dédié au
trophée de guerre la majorité de ces
crânes qui étaient alignée sur des
étagères de bois avant que le bâtiment
br ûle semble avoir appartenu à de
jeunes hommes et 10 d'entre eux à des
enfants donc improbable pour un culte
des ancêtres mais plausible pour une
chasse aux têtes
[Musique]
hypothèse numéro 4 des sacrifices
humains
enfin dernière hypothèse il n'est pas
exclure que ses crânes soient des
vestiges de sacrifices humains il y a en
particulier un site qui permet de
l'envisager ces deux moustp en Turquie
ce site tardif à livrer notamment une
poterie décorée qui illustre le même
thème des vautours et corps sans tête
les humains sont allongés nus par terre
sans leur tête et sont entourées par des
oiseaux schématisés peut-être des
vautours une tête semble être
représentée à côté du corps en bas et un
humain à droite et debout vêtu il
pourrait s'agir d'une représentation
d'un chef victorieux au combat dominant
ses ennemis vaincus ou bien il pourrait
s'agir d'autre chose car à domus TP les
archéologues ont fait une découverte
particulièrement macabre une grande
fausse à livrer des ossements d'au moins
35 humains mélangés avec ceux de chèvre
mouton porc bovin et chien les ossements
humains présentés par ailleurs de
nombreuses traces de coups et de
découpes des articuler raclées et même
briser pour extraire la moelle ils
évoquent clairement des sacrifices avec
une pratique de cannib à côté de la
fosse des inhumations isolées dont un
crâne montrait des traces de coûts et de
décapitation un peu plus loin un crâne
d'enfant de 6 ans est associé à un crâne
de cochon une corne et un pot en
céramique le corps sans tête de
jeffelarma qu'on a déjà évoqué gisant
sur le sol du bâtiment communautaire et
évidemment à rapprocher d'un sacrifice
la mise en scène est impressionnante et
9000 ans plus tard et glace toujours le
sang la jeune femme décapitée a été
étendue par terre au centre de la pièce
juste avant que le bâtiment ne soit
détruit et condamné pas de doute
inspecteur c'est un homicide c'est
découverte exceptionnelles nous font
entrevoir des pratiques bien différentes
d'un simple rythme funéraire la
décapitation des squelettes a peut-être
avoir avec des sacrifices de quoi une
nouvelle fois revoir l'interprétation de
trouvailles anciennes la décapitation
des figurines anthropomorphes souvent
associées à des accidents de
conservation aurait pu être une pratique
volontaire comme pour mettre à mort
symboliquement les stat avant de les
enterrer la dame au fauves de Chatta
loyuk où les nombreuses statues
d'angazal à la tête mutilée serait dès
lors des imitations de ces rituels
meurtriers au terme de cette explication
il faut bien avouer que c'est symboles
conservent une bonne part de mystère
finalement vous le voyez venir il n'y a
pas de réponse définitive en fonction
des cas il est même possible que les
quatre pratiques qu'on a décrites et
cohabitée car elles sont chacune étayées
par des trouvailles archéologiques
solides la vraisemblablement coexister
des pratiques concernant les ancêtres et
les ennemis les crânes retrouvées avec
leur mandibule et leur première
vertèbres toujours en place ont été
décapités avant des compositions sans
doute sur des ennemis tandis que les
squelettes trouvaient avec leur mâchoire
mais sans crâne montre qu'il a été
prélevé bien après des compositions sans
doute sur des ancêtres il y a au moins
deux pratiques qui se superposent et
puis il est pas exclure qu'on y
comprenne rien ou presque si ça se
trouve on mélange tout vu depuis le 21e
siècle après Jésus-Christ
avec seulement quelques dizaines de
sites archéologiques à se mettre sous la
dent
le symbole des crânes et des vautours
semble avoir une signification unique
pendant 4000 ans mais c'est peut-être un
biais dans nos sources archéologiques ou
une erreur d'interprétation en tout cas
la persistance de ce symbole dans la
très longue durée fait penser qu'il y
avait un ancrage mythologique des
animaux représentés sont relativement
les mêmes entre les sites de la région
serpent renard panthère au rock en y
ajoutant les vautours et les corps sans
tête il y a peut-être là un récit
cohérent des éléments d'une mythologie
qui nous échappe mais qui a structuré
pendant des millénaires l'imaginaire des
premiers agriculteurs et peut-être que
de nouvelles découvertes nous en
apprendrons plus un de ces jours merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo merci à mon
équipe pour m'avoir aidé à la réaliser
si vous voulez soutenir la chaîne vous
pouvez le faire via
utip il y a le lien ici là dans le petit
i c'est sans engagement et chaque don
est précieux pour me permettre de
produire ces vidéos je vous donne
rendez-vous dans 15 jours pour un nouvel
épisode de
Julien d'ici là vous pouvez me retrouver
sur Instagram sur Tik Tok et même sur
twitch les mercredis à 19h je suis
partout
ah dans 15 jours salut
[Musique]